for the last 18 years the world has been
following what can only be described as
a failed strategy to tackle global
warming we promised lots of carbon cups
but none have occurred we promised in
1992 and Rio yet we didn't do it in
Keota in 1997 we promised even more
carbon cuffs and virtually didn't do any
of them and of course in Copenhagen last
year we had a complete breakdown instead
of going further down that road to
nowhere of Rio Kyoto Copenhagen we
should be focusing on a different and
very very much simpler strategy we
should be investing dramatically more in
research and development into green
energy because if we can make green
energy cheaper than fossil fuels we will
all switch not just rich well-meaning
Westerners but also China and India and
everybody else so fundamentally we
should be pledging to spend 0.2 percent
of our gdp on research and development
into green energy technology it'll be
half the cost of Kyoto it will be 50
times more than what we're spending
currently on research and development
and the amazing thing is that for every
dollar spent we will avoid 500 times
more climate damage in the long run so
we can do more good much more
effectively at lower costs that ought to
be the solution for the future